that's question it came with a hit but
before we talk about that I just want to
still look at this question just on face
of it and see why a kit is given so your
organizes next time even if you don't
get it okay how can we tackle this thing
when you look at it what kinds of
strategies do we have in our belt that
we could try any suggestions I can't do
very much you go straight to the hip I'm
going to talk about that in a second
okay vincy yet a suggestion okay you
could try a substitution right now what
you say all right that's right a
substitution by B let u equal 1 plus cos
x or let u equal just cos x by itself
that ends up being problematic though
because if we're expecting such a
substitution where we change the
variable of integration what are we
going to introduce when we change it
we're getting you to sign right because
you need the derivative of that cause
and I don't see it anywhere there what
else could I do okay so you could try it
so what we what we're looking for there
is i'm looking for a square right i can
deal with squares so this is for
difference of squares if i multiply
through ads right on suggested by 1
minus cos x i'm gonna get 1 minus cos
squared or the denominator and that's
going to give me one over sine square on
the northern and I could actually I
could do some work with that okay now
that's got a little more Barrett there
there previous one but you can see as
well it's sort of excessive complicate
things right so that's a much more
property at the other Avenue which we
could take do is that we can try and use
some other kind of identity we just
thought about the type of going it'll
kill ya Diddy they suggest is that Jenna
that you said right you can look at this
you can take our what about double angle
double eagle is not at all the first
thing you would think because there are
no double angles there except there is I
mean really there's a double angle you
can make a double angle anywhere because
just you got it max you got to X where
your theater too thin if you double
something or have it do you have those
kinds of forms you can use to use under
the right here what solution am I going
to introduce I've
this is the integral of 1 on 1 plus now
to write X and take advantage of all the
things i know about double angle i'm
going to write the X is 2 times x over 2
there's my double equal to it just
happens if your anger to think again is
excellent so now this is in the fall 1
plus cos 2 theta where R theta happens
to be excellent to what identity could I
get out of this where did this come from
okay so yeah if you if you want to think
the line before this is cos 2 theta
which is 2 cos squared theta minus 1 you
remember that okay so that's why the
minus 1 came over here it's plus 1 so
what you really have is two cos squared
theta cube now as I've just established
the theta that I'm thinking about is X
or two ok so I'm going to do my
substitution over here 1 plus cos 2
theta is 2 cos squared theta in which
for this case is excellent too yes okay
now that's that's the hardest part of
this recognizing there's that identity
there which is not at all obvious and
that's part of what extent it is about
we're going to like just way out to be
more work with all the number of kinds
of functions you can integrate and
recognize it is part of the hardest
thing so suggestions what I do now okay
now interestingly I could take the half
hour but there's something else I could
do which actually will they be to keep
the half ear whatever cos squared that's
still a bit of a mess how can I write
that before we make it easier for me to
integrate its x squared isn't it so when
I see that that'll be sec square see how
as an exon 2 then that means it's
reverse chain rule that means i want the
derivative of the inside function which
she is a half which I have in this I'm
glad it's all just let him stay put aha
set square X outside
it's or two okay and now you can see
right that's about a standard as it gets
really that's 10 of X on to possibly
constant okay obviously there's no hard
if you took that heart out but then you
long enough to put the heart back in and
they have school okay so though they
sense you see that so the hit that was
given to you was try the double angle
formula but now that you know like the
double angle formula B used in reverse
right and that's exactly what we did
with T results right if t equals term of
theater on to write then we can say okay
tan theta is equal to t on what matters
to you squared right end of your sine
cosine of all of these like you see how
using this comes out of using the double
leg before right so every w affording
that is a half angle formula in disguise
we just got used to using that attitude
or extension one context because it's an
extension to skip okay all right now
that's all I'm going to say really about
the standard trig integrals that you're
going to encounter let's have a look at
the inverse trig interviews you going to
see and I'm going to push a little
further plus the standard forms that
you've seen and have a look at where we
need to muck around with the algebra
please okay so here's one that I just
have to go out so this is example to
okay so I'm giving you an enormous leg
up on this question because like I said
like you can counter this Senate exam
and this there's nothing that's it
there's no context there's nothing that
that tells you hey big red flashing sign
this is the kind of integral you're
going to encounter okay but one of the
things we met in extension why was it's
weird but it's unavoidable even if you
have something it's just just algebraic
er you don't always end up with a
drafter you integrate sometimes you end
up with a true function in those trig
functions right so be ended up giving
you this enormous clue or hey this is
going to be inverse trig of some kind
right what clothes do you have in the
integrand that tell you what direction
you might be heading yeah okay so and
hang around me for too long so what I
look at this right when I think about
inverse tree I've really only got two
oceans don't know I mean I've got three
but two of them are identical except for
a negative sign I'm either going to have
1 over the square root of a quadratic
I'm gonna have one over I quadratic
right so when I look at this this is
leading me towards where is that going
to go what will these women it's going
to be tan inverse of some kind hey but
it's not at all obvious like I I'm if I
had something like that then I could
deal with okay but what's the difference
between this and this
yeah there's actually like this extra
term here means a horizontal shift okay
actually means more than a horizontal
shift but we'll do with that a second so
what I want is I want this de nada to
look something like one on like 1 plus u
square or at least like a squared plus u
squared where you is my variable and a
is a cliff okay so here's how I'm going
to make that happen we all headed
completing the square back in the day
because we're like oh don't just give to
the court date or not but I hope I've
convinced you since then completing the
square super useful context like this is
perfect right I wanted something square
so I can't just have x squared I'm going
to have to have something else square
head and that of function is my your
dual substitution or sometimes so what
square is hiding inside here when you
complete this way up yeah this is X plus
200 square now where does that come from
right what I'm doing in my mind is
saying this really is x squared plus 4x
plus for that's the completion of the
square but I have I don't have for their
so on top of the 4 i've got a left obat
a remainder you have to see what I've
done so all I've done is you've
rearranged a little bit so that I see
this format come be on is that make
sense okay at this point not compulsory
but I'm going to do it anyway I'm going
to say let u equal x plus 2 it's simple
enough I think that you probably could
do this in your head but you guys know
how skeptical eye out of that way over
your head so I'm going to do all the
steps of the substitution properly
that's a you it's one so that means i
can put the do DX wherever I like when I
do my switching down back I'm gonna
actually do the substitution I'm going
to put that do you on DX on the
numerator so he's nice and easy to
cancel with the DX it's already there
and then on the denominator i have one
cool i'm even going to go ahead and
write that as u squared plus 3 square
now you do have this on your reference
sheet but do you remember what
you get what the standard form is when
you can do meant something this one good
i'm going to have one on a x tan inverse
of X on it right which well in this case
my actual variable is new isn't it so
I'm going to have you on three there and
it's in deference oh there's my positive
injury okay right we've done all the
hard legwork let's just tie this thing
up go back to exes because that's where
the question begins and I'm home all
right okay yes yep so if you can see it
is and recognized that is in this fall
and go straight here go for it go to
feel life if you're confident obviously
you save all of this time okay and which
on this board is like almost like like a
third of the work there or at least the
time of writing and so that's that's
okay in much the same way if I saw this
question
I'd be sorry is that what I want that's
what the exactly Basel to see what's
inside I've got the wrong way if I saw
that I'd be a little bit disappointed if
any of you r in a head into this
substitution I'd expect you to just go
straight to the fall okay because yeah
this is what we learnt these months and
months ago but yeah here I have done it
because I'm still I'm still kind of new
with these industry interest that's okay